they knew that this bill didn't ban
Books Okay because we had already
discussed that the day before in the
rules committee before the debate came
to the whole house they they knew it
didn't ban books but they went down
there and said it anyways because they
knew a lot of their constituents
wouldn't do the due diligence to find
that yeah or and stated a little bit
differently the bill yeah the bill does
nothing to do that what it does do is
Empower parents and they come in and go
well you're just going to empower this
mob to go after well hold on a second so
there are books that I don't want to be
in the school library let me be
perfectly clear the question is is which
Library Elementary and high school and
then parents should be able to have to
say there that's literally all this this
bill did was say parents should be able
to know
foreign
Rubin Thomas Massey chip Roy how's that
for an intro sounds good to me nailed it
solid this is it this is the end of my
little DC tour I'm finishing up with you
guys something about this giant table I
I feel like this could end both of your
careers right now
you guys are on trial right now uh all
right Thomas I gotta start with you
because everyone's gonna be wondering
about that thing right there yeah you
have the debt clock on your lapel yeah
where's yours
um you know
um some people have a pacemaker up here
a lot of these old Senators I've got an
anxiety maker I'm trying to make their
hearts skip beats and become concerned
uh by looking at the debt increasing
each day it goes I wrote the software in
here I made the case I've got some 3D
printed ones I'm working on so Chip Roy
can have a copy but it goes to the
treasury's website once a day gets the
actual debt to the penny and then makes
its best guess based on the average debt
per sec and over the last year about
what the debt is at this very moment I'm
going to guess that when you're back
home in Kentucky or I should say
Kentucky and Texas of course when you're
back home in Kentucky people probably
dig it you come here and everyone's like
could you put that thing away a little
bit of that uh the Democrats I had one
in an elevator look at it and say is
that a Doomsday Clock and I said yes
ma'am it is well they're always
escalating escalating that situation uh
so you guys are on the on the freedom
side of things I would say you're you're
on the what I would generally call the
more libertarian side Freedom side of
things I sense after three days here
that that really is the direction that
the Republican party is going in do you
agree with that or am I just being uh
pollyanish
uh I mean I'll say that I think that is
certainly there's more of an appetite
for that among a larger block of the
Republican party that doesn't
necessarily mean that's the overall
direction we still have a lot of people
we've got to get there right um there is
still an enormous dominance of what I
would call the war caucus in this town
um and you know I say that as someone a
child of the 80s and very much believe
in a very strong military use sparingly
but forcefully but we've got a kind of
Stranglehold on this place of the way
we've always done things and part of the
issue here with freedom is reminding
people why we have a limited government
of diffused powers and why that's
important for preserving and protecting
our rights nothing illuminated that more
than covid nothing illuminated the
dangers with centralizing power and
giving power to a handful of cronies
like Anthony fauci than what we just
witnessed Thomas has been you know one
of the leaders on that along with Rand
Paul I've tried to help in others but
we've got to continue to elevate that
there's an increased appetite for it but
in part because these people in
Washington respond to their constituents
there's a lot of Americans who want us
to preserve and protect Liberty let's be
honest let's be honest though the um the
fight that happened the first week of
January over who would be the next
speaker was very consequential and a lot
of people say oh that looked so bad you
know the Republican party was in
disarray no that is how it's supposed to
work we're not supposed to like have all
these backroom deals and everything's
baked and what came out of that is uh
actually chip Roy and I ended up on the
rules committee along with Ralph Norman
so conservatives the people who are most
likely to advocate for Freedom through
legislation have a blocking position on
every bill that comes to the floor now
and also for the first time since I've
been in Congress we're actually imposing
time to read the bills like here we are
three months into this session and every
bill that's come to the floor you've had
72 hours to read now 72 hours I know
people back home we're like there's not
time to read a bill in 72 hours better
than 72 minutes yes 72 minutes is the
norm right right and the other thing is
72 hours gives people back home time to
read about it in the news and then call
the other Congressman right so it's a
heads up you know you could give our
colleagues a year to read a bill and
some of them are not going to read it or
they could read it know what's in it
know it's bad and still vote for it
what's important is the American people
have a chance in the news cycle to find
out what's going on up here call their
congressman and influence it so to that
point I I sat down with speaker McCarthy
at the Capitol yesterday and I sensed
actually now maybe maybe it wasn't when
you guys were in the fight that he kind
of is happy with the results like I
think he does feel like maybe it
empowered him a little bit by you guys
pushing do you think that's fair look I
think that's fair I mean of course she's
happy the results because he got to be
speakers
but but In fairness to Kevin right I
mean yesterday he sent a letter to to
the to the president United States
detailing some spending restraint that a
lot of us have been pushing for he did
uphold his end of the bargain and
ensuring that several of us got on the
rules committee that we have more
conservatives on the Appropriations
Committee and other committees uh that
we've been adhering to a number of the
rules that we had asked for back in
December so all of that's good and I
think when that happens there's there's
a Unity that builds around that now
getting to 218 on anything is hard and
you gotta only lose four five six guys
or gals and you're you know it's
difficult but um look I think what we
saw coming out of January Was A Renewed
spirit that you know when it when some
people stand up on what they believe you
can prove that the sky's not going to
fall you can have 435 people in the
chamber debating stuff and actually move
the needle rather than just kind of
retreating to your Corners doing press
conferences and walking away and I think
we showed that and I think Kevin's
beneficiary of that yeah let me give an
example of how the new system actually
works out for Kevin so he to get the
majority he went out and did a lot of
campaigning and one of his signature
issues that a lot of people care about
is reclaiming our schools basically
letting parents know what their kids are
learning and so there was a bill was
coming to the floor hr5 that would that
would impose a requirement on every
school system in the United States that
you publish your curriculum and the
books and the list of the books that are
in your library so parents real fascist
stuff yeah right yeah well believe it or
not chip Roy and I had a small issue
with that bill which a lot of members of
our conference did we were like well you
know we prefer the Department of
Education doesn't even exist like so the
question like if by reforming it or
directing it are we violating our
principle of federalism and leaving
things up to the states and so uh they
asked me is there any way you can vote
for this bill and I said yeah if we have
an amendment on the bill that eliminates
the Department of Education like if I
can show a preference uh it
legislatively through my votes on the
floor not just say something on a
website that my preference is to get rid
of this department rather than reform it
I could vote for the final bill regards
to how it turns out well I was pleasant
and Chip was the same way he was able to
offer some amendments that would require
dollars to be block granted to the
states which would be sort of the next
step like I favor abolishing it but if
you can't do that can we at least just
give it to the states and let them
decide and if you can't do that can we
at least let the dollars eventually get
to the parents to be able to just use
themselves so we got to votes on all
three of those amendments and what
surprised me is uh Kevin voted to remove
all the power from the Department
Federal Department of Education yeah to
micromanage uh Elementary and secondary
education so for the first time since
Jimmy Carter set up this Department of
Education as a re-election Ploy that
failed we had a referendum in the House
of Representatives on whether they
should exist or not in our schools back
home and Kevin joined us on saying no
they shouldn't give back to the schools
so this might sound sort of The Amateur
hour but so the the department obviously
is still going to exist but it just
won't have authorization when it comes
to these types of issues that's yeah and
let me be clear before everybody gets
really excited our amendments didn't
pass right and but we still voted for
the final bill yeah because we got a
chance to put everybody on record and
now people back home can say would I
rather have a congressman that wants to
take the federal government out of my
kids education or congressman who wants
the federal government well and one
final point on that to your point so
what did we pass we passed legislation
as Thomas described that empowers
parents to know what their kids are
being taught we put on the record a
whole bunch of garbage books with all
sorts of total smut and ridiculous
things that were in libraries and in
curriculum and we were demonstrating
that that's the underlying Bill and
that's the underlying bill but for me to
get comfortable with Federal power being
used to go tell a local school district
you're going to require parents to be
able to see this stuff I need to
demonstrate that my personal preference
is to get the feds out of it all
together together but in the absence of
that then yeah a parent ought to have a
right to at least know how these dollars
are being used and what's being taught
to their kids and so I think getting
that series of votes restoring the way
things work which is a part of that
agreement empowered Kevin and empowered
us to come together yeah but just to Cap
all that that bill probably would have
failed correct and Kevin one of his
major initiatives that he campaigned on
wouldn't have been able to pass in a
majority if we don't fix the rules if we
didn't have uh if we didn't help him put
into the process and ability for
conservatives to express their
preference so was the calculation by you
guys that yes you would prefer that the
federal government not do anything but
not every state is going to do what
perhaps Texas and Kentucky and certainly
Florida Iowa Arkansas a couple other
states are doing right now so it was
sort of your only way in essence right
because Cali is never going to do this
sort of thing New York Etc well I mean
again and going back to preferences
right I would rather even though I think
what California doing is does is insane
yeah I would rather just get the feds
out of it and say if you want to be
insane in California go ahead but don't
mess with my kids in Texas or don't mess
with the kids in Kentucky but in the
absence of that if we're going to as we
do currently have federal dollars flow I
think it is within reason of me being
able to say I would prefer this other
outcome to be able to go in and say that
yeah parents have a right and frankly
even in Texas and Kentucky it's not like
it's not like every parent in Texas
knows exactly what's going on so where
those federal dollars are flowing now
they'll have a little bit more ability
to push for that so when you guys when
you guys see AOC afterwards talk about
how this bill was basically passed by
fascist and it's like man she needs some
better education because you don't know
what it means or Hakeem Jeffries you
know they don't want to teach about the
Holocaust I mean these are the responses
you got out of these guys
I've asked this to every Republican I've
sat down with for last three days are
you talking to these guys in the back
rooms going what the hell are you
talking about you know that's not legit
um so I mean in the rules committee we
debated this and Chip was right to point
out they knew that this bill didn't ban
Books Okay because we had already
discussed that the day before in the
rules committee before the debate came
to the whole house they they knew it
didn't ban books but they went down
there and said it anyways because they
knew a lot of their constituents
wouldn't do the due diligence to find
that yeah or and state it a little bit
differently the bill yeah the bill does
nothing to do that what it does do is
Empower parents and they come in and go
well you're just going to empower this
mob to go after well hold on a second so
there are books that I don't want to be
in the school library let me be
perfectly clear the question is is which
Library Elementary and high school and
then parents should be able to have the
say there that's literally all this this
bill did was saying parents should be
able to know did you guys see the the on
TV was it about a week ago DeSantis is
going through the books that they've
removed it's basically two books that
were pretty much pornographic and the
media the mainstream media had to cut
away because they can't show pornography
on ABC I pulled up one of those books in
the committee that I was sitting on
where we had uh some some witnesses and
I was starting to show and I had to stop
like I showed the cover and then I
opened it I was like I can't show this I
literally couldn't put it on C-Span and
that's that's the kind of thing
but they wanted to say that they were
moving Clemente and Rosa Parks all false
those books were uh left on the shelves
or they were reviewed as part of a
process and then put back on the shelves
and that's the truth by the way they
they don't read the bills we vote on
I've read a few of their bills I've read
the green New Deal yeah because it's
only 14 pages and when I got done with
it I realized why it's only 14 pages
there's only 64 crayons in that big box
is the difference between Republicans
and Democrats right now sort of as wide
as as you've ever seen in your how many
years now in Congress ten and a half for
me how many for you yeah I'm in my third
term so foreign change yeah so is that
difference wider than ever right now
it's gotten wider uh uh the there were
some moderate Democrats when I first got
here they kind of just finally all got
washed out here in the they threw
attrition they were going down but
um you know I don't blame AOC for her
positions I really don't I blame the
people that voted for her like what what
you see here the division you see is it
truly is and people may not like when I
say this it's a reflection of the
American voters preferences and I think
the countries become more polarized and
that's why you see Congress more
polarized yeah if you look at
um right now right there are places in
the northeast or in certain sectors of
this country where the people are still
masked I mean put on you flip on like
the NBC control room right the control
room they're all sitting there in Mass
good grief mailing four years ago we
weren't wearing mask in Texas I went out
to Lakey Texas which I represent which
is a you know about two and a half hours
from my house and went out to a uh they
were doing goat roping and it was a
labor day uh weekend in 2020. of course
the the the the the Northeast Elites and
all that stuff I mean they're cowering
in their corners and hiding and masked
up these guys are all out you know the
kids and everybody were out in the rodeo
and their goat you know roping goats and
and uh we were all getting together and
having food and dinner it was totally
different worlds two different worlds
truly and that still exists today like
that divide that difference that
different view about how you do these
things and and I think that is reflected
in the representatives in Washington
which is which is why we need more
solutions that are state-based correct
rather than Federal you have to be able
to agree to disagree right I mean that's
my the reason I believe in federalism
and the reason I hedged a bit on the the
parents Rights bill and wanted to go
well because all things being equal the
only way this Republic survives is if we
can literally agree to disagree under
our federal system if we're going to
tell each other what to do it's going to
break us apart and that's what we've got
to figure out how is that really the
fight more than anything else because it
seems to me that the red States and you
guys know I lived in Cali and now I'm
I'm in Florida I feel like I live in a
different country but it seems to me
that the blue States will never stop
coming for the red States the red States
I think could for the most part be like
hey we're just going to take care of our
business and and that's it but the blue
states are not going to leave well
enough alone and I I sense that's what
uh is is a big oncoming fight what do
you think yeah I mean I certainly think
that's been that the direction things
have been going for a while I mean
certainly you know whether it's the kind
of Dei type stuff or whether it's for
example climate change right they're
gonna say well no you don't have a right
to be over there doing that they're
going to try to shut down our way of
life and kind of export frankly their
misery to the rest of us yeah
I don't want that imported you know look
one thing I do believe in though right
is that there's an ebb and flow to
things I do believe in the power of
ideas I believe in the power of freedom
I believe in the power the fundamental
principles upon which this country was
founded and that leaders of this country
have an obligation to project confidence
in those principles and go fight for
them
um you know I was talking to a group
this morning and you know all these the
folks that get you know June 6th and
D-Day and they talk about their dads or
granddads and their family they're
storing the beaches Normandy to wallow
bullets they talk about Washington
Crossing the Delaware or in Texas the
guys on the Alamo and you know I said oh
you're talking about all that pride and
then they go man you you're real
courageous in that speaker's fight
because they were tweeting mean things
about them look come on guys like if you
want to fight for Freedom just get out
there and say what you believe stand up
like I did at a chamber of commerce
event today and said Dei is garbage stop
promoting it it's hurting our recruiting
at the Department of Defense we've just
got to start being honest because I
think people want it I think DeSantis
shows that in Florida he wins by a
million and a half votes 62 percent of
Hispanics uh a 50 percent of single
women why because he led he wasn't
afraid of Disney he isn't afraid of the
universities he isn't afraid to take on
the establishment and take on all this
woke stuff he wasn't afraid to send a
shipment of folks to Martha's Vineyard
and then he won 62 percent Hispanics
people are tired of people who are
trying to buy their votes they want them
to lead people always people always
forget the guy only won by 30 000 votes
over a meth addict before so it's like
this is a big this is a big change yeah
yeah you know I do wish the the blue
States would leave the red States well
enough alone and I hear on you know the
mean things they say on Twitter right
but one of the things they gave back to
is oh Kentucky's a welfare state well
the blue the the Democrats are the ones
who are a voting number one to send the
money to Kentucky and their war on
poverty is hollowed out Appalachia thank
you very much you've you're on your
fourth generation of destroying our
culture so I prefer you just take your
welfare or whatever I don't vote for it
and and also remind them uh we just
printed five trillion dollars like the
government is spending money that the
states didn't send it that the people
didn't send it we've got 50 welfare
states at the moment like let's end the
welfare state for everybody all right
unfortunately we only got about three
minutes left and I'd definitely love to
have both you on for a proper sit down
when we have more time but
you mentioned DeSantis I saw you guys a
couple weeks ago at this blueprint event
that he's trying to really give the
states this is the plan to to fix
everything it seems like this Trump
DeSantis fight is coming you you jumped
in early DeSantis has not even said he's
running for president unless something
happened in the last 20 minutes or so uh
but you endorsed him already what was
your calculation on that yeah look I
think primaries are healthy I was
Senator Cruz the chief of staff it was
healthy in 2016. but nobody gets
anointed in this country I don't care if
you're Ted Cruz who came in second or if
you're president Trump who was president
uh Ron DeSantis just because you're
strong in Florida nobody gets annoying
it you got to run so I support Governor
DeSantis I'm not afraid of that he's a
good man I've known him for a decade
he's done amazing things in Florida
we've already talked about it I think we
need to have a robust debate about where
we want to carry this country forward I
would like to have someone who can serve
for eight years I'd like to have
somebody who's not a baby boomer I'd
like to have somebody who has proven
track record of conservatism so um
that's where I am
you might get some Mean Tweets you know
it's all good so you know I like both
candidates uh but let's be honest uh
Rhonda Sanders was at the tip of the
spear on fighting back against Cove and
tyranny if uh we'd had somebody like
that in the White House who would fired
fauci and Burks instead of giving them
commendations for their great jobs you
tweeted out a heck of a video of
trump kind of bungling things related to
fauci well I mean there was a lot of
fear I I you know the people understand
that the former president Trump hired a
lot of people that should have been
fired and we thought he would have fired
them but he didn't and
um so I haven't waited into the race yet
but I will say uh Governor Ron DeSantis
the best governor in the United States
there's no close second and I had the
privilege of serving with him for six
years in the House of Representatives
and people can go back and look at those
votes if they want to know where he
stands on federal issues he's very
strong conservative I'm going to pull a
Joe Biden here you just
pleasure guys thank you very much
yeah God bless
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell